حسنًا، إلى متى ستقاتل من أجل
العدالة إذا رأيت جزءًا من
مدينتك قد سوي بالأرض في غمضة عين، وإذا
انفجرت نوافذ منزلك
وتحطمت من حولك، إذا قُتل المئات في
مدينتك ولم تتم محاسبة أحد
على الإطلاق.  في مثل هذا اليوم منذ سنوات، وقع أحد
أكبر الانفجارات غير النووية
المسجلة على الإطلاق في بيروت في
لبنان، والآن في الذكرى الثالثة
لذلك الانفجار المدمر، يتم
الاحتفال بيوم حداد، ونحن نعلم
أن الانفجار نشأ في مستودع
مليء بنترات الأمونيوم الذي كان  تم
تخزينها بشكل غير صحيح لسنوات ولكن حتى الآن
لم يتم الانتهاء من أي تحقيق رسمي في سبب
الانفجار نفسه
بشكل جيد. لقد كنت على الهواء عندما تلقت شبكة سي إن إن خبر
الانفجار ولن أنسى أبدًا
تلك الصور، ولا يمكن لأحد في لبنان بكل
صراحة أن ينسى بن ويدمان من سي إن إن  كان
يقيم في بيروت في ذلك الوقت
وشهد ذلك وشعر به وعاش
فيه وأريد فقط أن آخذكم
جميعًا إلى ما كانت عليه تلك اللحظة المروعة، حيث
حصلنا للتو على بعض الصور في
CNN لما يعتبر انفجارًا كبيرًا أه في
العاصمة اللبنانية بيروت، سمع شهود عيان،
بما في ذلك مراسلونا هناك،
انفجارًا ورأوا
دخانًا ولم يصدر أي كلمة حتى الآن عن سبب
هذا الفيديو الذي وصل للتو إلى شبكة سي إن إن ويظهر
لحظة الانفجار، أول
هذه الصور مأخوذة من قارب قريب
ما الأمر
وهذا  فيديو فيديو آخر
جاء للتو يظهر لحظة ذلك
الانفجار أه في هذا الفيديو التالي ستشاهد
سحابة ضخمة من الدخان
واللهب
الصليب الأحمر اللبناني يعطي فكرة
عن نطاق تأثير هذه
الكارثة التي تواجه
بيروت اليوم تغرد  أقتبس أكثر من 30
فريقًا يستجيبون للانفجار
هذا الصليب الأحمر اللبناني يرجى إفساح
المجال لسيارات الإسعاف لدينا
جيدًا بن ويدرمان من بين
الأضرار الأخرى التي انضمت إلينا من بيروت أه
بن ماذا
نفهم أنه حدث في هذه
المرحلة
حسنًا وقع هذا الانفجار في
سبق منطقة المرفأ نوع من
الحريق، كما يبدو في مستودع
يحتوي على ألعاب نارية، وفقًا لوكالة الأنباء الوطنية اللبنانية الرسمية،
ولكن كما شعرنا به، وفي هذا المبنى، كان
مكتب CNN
يبدو وكأنه زلزال يتبعه
انفجار ضخم أدى إلى تحطيم النوافذ في
هذا ما كان في السابق الاستوديو الخاص بنا وإطارات
النوافذ بالإضافة إلى تحريك
الكاميرا من حولك يمكنك الحصول على فكرة عن
مستوى الضرر الذي حدث وهذا
الضرر بالطبع
يتكرر في معظم أنحاء وسط
بيروت
حسنًا، أصبح الأمر أكثر وضوحًا على مدار ساعات
الدمار، هذا بلد
عانى من مأساة تلو الأخرى
عامًا بعد عام وعقدًا بعد عقد. لقد
عاش الشعب اللبناني
حربًا أهلية مروعة استمرت 15 عامًا أعقبتها
حرب دموية أخرى مع إسرائيل بعد أقل من
عقد من الزمان.  ناهيك لاحقًا عن
الاقتصاد المعوق الذي ظل في
حالة من الانهيار منذ سنوات، في
الرابع من أغسطس من عام 2020، اندفع الناس بشكل محموم في
جميع أنحاء المدينة بحثًا عن
أحبائهم المفقودين متسائلين عن سبب
تعريضهم لمصيرهم مرة أخرى
لمأساة أخرى ولماذا
لم يفعل قادتهم شيئًا لحمايتهم من
هذا الانفجار المروع، لقد فكرت في كل
هذا في أعقاب الانفجار،
وللأسف، الكثير مما قلته آنذاك لا يزال قائمًا
حتى اليوم، استمعوا،
هذه هي الطريقة التي تقطعونها بها
مظهرًا للجموع  من
مسارات لا نهاية لها من الفساد البائس
في لبنان، ما يُنظر إليه على أنه
الأوليغارشية السياسية، قام على مدى عقود بإفراغ
البلاد بأكملها من الداخل في
سلسلة لا نهاية لها ومتفاقمة بلا توقف من الخلل
الوظيفي والسرقة أمس
الثلاثاء 4 أغسطس في وقت مبكر من
المساء، رأينا  المثال الأكثر روعة على
ذلك، حيث تم تدمير جزء كبير من المدينة
في انفجار لم يسبق له مثيل، وترك
الكثيرون يتساءلون عن سبب
تخزين نترات الأمونيوم في
الميناء، وكم من الوقت كانت هناك، ومن كان يعلم
عنها ومخاطرها، ومن كان يعرف عنها؟  غضت
الطرف عن ذلك، على الرغم من أن هذا مجرد أحدث وأوضح
مثال على نظام أوسع بكثير من
الخلل الوظيفي، حيث
فشلت حكومة تلو الأخرى في لبنان في القيام
بمهمتها الأساسية ورعاية
شعبها، حتى أصبحت بيروت الآن تزين ذات يوم مثل
باريس الشرق الأوسط.  تقع
بين مياه البحر الأبيض
المتوسط ​​الزبرجد وتلك التلال المذهلة
في مونتليبان، وهي ممزقة ومدمرة على
نطاق لا يزال غير مفهوم مرة أخرى،
لم يكن هذا الانفجار حتميًا، ولم تكن
الأزمة الاقتصادية حتمية ولا انقطاع
التيار الكهربائي ولا نقص الوظائف
والأنظمة الأساسية  في جميع أنحاء الطيف السياسي في لبنان،
تسود أيديولوجية واحدة،
ما في الأمر بالنسبة لي، ومن ثم لم
يبق للشعب
سوى اليأس في كثير من الأحيان.